veterans who were stripped of their
medals because of their sexual
orientation are to have them restored
lgbt plus people weren't allowed to
serve in the armed forces until the year
2000
with several hundred being thrown out
each year the ministry of defence now
says personnel sacked for their
sexuality
will be able to reclaim awards that were
confiscated when
they left it's the result of a legal
campaign by veteran
joe osilicher who forced the mod to
review its policies
and we're able to speak to him now joe
hello to you thanks very much
indeed for being with us what does this
announcement mean
to you well it's certainly very
interesting but the first i heard about
it was last night from my solicitor emma
norton um
i spoke to the defense secretary a year
ago
who confirmed that they they would
actually give
all these veterans the medals back and
they were at the end of the process
now that was over a year ago he he said
he would contact me
every four months with an update i've
heard nothing
since and as i said last night was the
first i heard about it so yes
it's it's a good result if indeed
it does it does happen but i've heard
this so many times over the last 28
years
yeah so you're not convinced at this
stage
joe just tell us a little bit about your
story you were court-martialed you were
dismissed from
the royal navy in 1993 is that right
what impact did it have on your life
well it totally devastated me my whole
life revolved around the navy
um i had all my friends in the navy
i was in a very good secure job um
i had pg superior write-ups in every one
of my write-ups by the
the armed forces and yet overnight they
can make a sad story up as such
and just kicked me out um the
the day before i was chucked out of
the navy i had to go and see the
commanding officer of hms portland
who reliably insured me that disgusting
people such as me
had no place in a civilized world and in
particular in the armed forces
the knock-on effect then on your life
joe was devastating wasn't it
it certainly was i lost my home i lost
my car
i lost my girlfriend um i was out into
my family
and in the end i was living off pinched
cabbages and potatoes from farmers
fields
because i had no money coming in um
it affected me so much that i was living
in a bubble
and in the end i thought life's not
worth living and then i decided to jump
off the taymor bridge
it's only just before i got to the
bridge that a friend of mine phoned me
up
and talked me out of it and this is the
the effect of the
you know the their actions and
until that point that the royal navy had
been your life
oh yeah everything revolved around the
navy
um i've been around the world several
times i've been to the south atlantic
for the falklands
six tours of duty in northern ireland
twice in the middle east and a two-year
forced into hong kong
what would you like to see happen now
um to make up to repair some of the harm
that has been done well i urge the mod
to set up an ex gratia compensation fund
to which
lgbt veterans may apply for some form of
financial recompense
and i hope that the restoration of
medals is just the first in a series
of steps only then will the mob be able
to say that it truly addresses this
historic injustice
but which is responsible i'd also like
it possible for the queen to
have a pardon for all these people who
lost their their
their jobs yeah and as you've described
so much more
than the jobs in terms of the process um
you have to reapply this doesn't happen
automatically does it you've got to
reapply
and go through a review process is that
right
what's that for sorry in terms of
getting the medals
returned and restored to members of the
armed forces you've got to reapply for
them it isn't automatic
oh no it isn't automatic i don't know
what it is
you know today because i said i'd left
over 28 years ago
but you have to do 12 years
of unblemished work with the armed
forces to
get an lsd um on service and good
conduct medal
um you get that over with three year
epilets
um and if you lose you know if you get
one bit of trouble in your in your navel
career
you lose that medal
what do you think this says about the
ministry of defense's approach
to lgbt military personnel
now and a potentially different future
i'm not altogether sure to be honest
because they they say one thing to your
face and yet do something completely
different
for example you know i spoke to several
admirals
a year ago when they get the return my
medal
i was assured that they would return the
medals to all these other veterans
immediately and yet here i am a year
down the line
and still none of these veterans have
got the medals back
surely i'm not the only one the charity
is supporting me the center for military
justice
i'm fighting with pride i've received
lots of inquiries from people like me
all of these veterans have described the
life-long
impact that the benefit that banners had
the public humiliation the living in
fear
the verbal and sometimes physical abuse
being outed to friends
family and colleagues and strangers and
that the financial impact on
losing their career and pensions some of
them are now getting
on in years some are getting ill and
some are dying
almost all of us are poorer than what we
should have been
so you know they need to sort themselves
out